David Caldicott
I have, personally, very limited experience of the issue of bushfire smoke.
There are no snakes in Ireland.
There's very little bushfire smoke in Ireland.
So this is all pretty novel, from a medical perspective.
When the smoke closed in
it was quite surreal. Initially, the people who were most affected were those of high susceptibility.
And any man in the street
would be able to guess who they might be:
people who've got long-standing respiratory disease. People who've got very sensitive airways,
like the asthmatics.
And also there's a tendency for young kids and the elderly to also be susceptible.
We sort of saw a gradual drift.
There was an immediate effect where we saw quite a few of those people who were
affected and then a gradual increase in those who have less severe disease
presenting to our hospitals.